i read the script and there was no snake
and then right bef you know
not right before but there was some time
but
you know weeks before we started he said
oh by the way you're dancing with a
snake and i'm like
that's my greatest fear in life
desperado and once upon a time in mexico
it was not
only my first lead in an american movie
it was my first american movie
actually and robert rodriguez is super
specific
so the character is created by him he
wrote it for me which is that helps
and it was he's it's just very easy with
him you know he moves very fast
and antonio was really cool and
lovely and fun to work with is that him
yes you're not doing anything to him
around here all you'll get is both
killed and i don't want to die over this
okay
stay away from the windows before they
see
[Music]
i kind of understood that
it's not really a choice you have to do
your stunts and so i was doing all the
stunts and it was also my first time
doing stunts and
antonio also did all his stunts and so
we had a lot of fun with the movie we
have
i was very proud and scared
i remember jumping from one building to
another one
and scrapping all my my knees and was
full of blood
and i said i don't care i'll do it again
and it was really painful but
i did it again anyway you know it was my
first movie and
and i just i wanted to prove myself and
i
i wanted to to show that i cared for the
movie and i was professional so no
matter what happened i just
would do it
the most drop dead gorgeous woman you'll
ever see
[Music]
do you have to remember that also robert
rodriguez gets involved with a wardrobe
and the light he operates the camera
he practically does your makeup i mean
he does he was doing like
everything in every department then
when we were gonna shoot once upon a
time in mexico
i had a much bigger role in that one
except that there was a threat
of um i think was the actor's guild
going on strike and that we were
not going to be able to work for some
time so all these movies
started shooting at the same time and i
have been trying to do frida for like
eight years and exactly at the same time
they were both going i said robert i
have to do this movie
he had to rewrite the script really fast
so that i wouldn't be in it and just i
mean it of course but
a lot less and he said i'll trade you
i'll do that for you
because he had me by contract he could
have said no you don't do friday you
have to do this movie and
i will let you do free that i will make
your
your part smaller i will save it for the
end but you have to sing the end credits
song
and i was so terrified of that but we
did it and by the way
that i came at the end of friday so
tired
and my stunts in once upon a time in
mexico
were a lot more complicated than in
desperado
and i was so tired but we did it from
thus till dawn
they were doing a movie called four
rooms
where each one of them it was uh robert
rodriguez and and
and quentin alexander's i'm sorry i
don't remember the fourth
uh director but in robert's
short the kids are watching television
and there
is like a stripper on the television
and i was not in that movie at all and
one morning
i they i'm woken up at like five
in the morning i'm on the phone like
what hello what happened
and robert says i need you to come right
now to the set i need you to do me a
favor i'm like what what
i need you to do something uh for the
movie it's just something quick on the
television
you just have to dance whatever and then
anyway i i get there and it
i have to like do like a street like a
strip lens and i'm like
what are you doing this to me i've never
done that before i don't know how to do
it and
he goes that's why i want to and like
what do you like you couldn't find a
stripper in l.a
he goes no i audition a lot of them but
because kids are watching it there's
something
a little bit you know something about it
that they look professional
it makes me feel uncomfortable and i
said but i have clothes you're gonna
wear your bikini okay
so i said i'll do it robert but
you cannot show my face
[Music]
or something like that and so we did it
and i think he didn't show my face but
he put me in the credits which is worse
but anyway quinton saw it and that's
where he got the idea
to write santanico pondemonium
then i read the script and there was no
snake
and then right bef you know not right
before but
there was some time but you know weeks
before we started
he said oh by the way you're dancing
with a snake and i'm like
that's my greatest fear in life and he
said
well let me do it let me know if you're
not capable of
overcoming your fear for a role because
we can always give it to madonna which i
mean
i'm sure it's not true because if they
could have had one
madonna why me but i was so afraid to
lose the part i thought i was going to
be able to convince him just let's do it
like in the script without the snake but
so
i had to learn how to go on trance
so that i could overcome my biggest fear
so i wasn't trans when i was doing that
dance
dogma the thing about that one is i was
so
impressed of the cast even
alanis mori said which at the time
you're too young but she was like the
biggest thing
on the first of the years with you know
little pill
and we had ben affleck and and matt
damon
right after the oscar uh linda
fiorentino who
also at that time was like the most you
know revere
actress she was so talented uh chris
rock
who again at the time was like number
one comedian
so just the cast was extraordinary and i
was
so excited to be a part of that group
kevin
it's it's so intelligent and and
and interesting and and fun
and he wanted me for that role so i was
just so excited to do it but
it was uh nerve-wracking a little bit
because it's so crazy the script
how do you know metatron how does she
know metatron this
is the last science you're kidding
and i play a muse and i think
what a lovely thing to play amuse muse
he did make me
do a strip dance on that one too
as i was chewing bubble gum
frida my connection with frida
and the movie it gave me a purpose
more than anything it was not a movie
she was my
my hero but also
it meant so much to me all the things i
wanted to complain about in the world
or change the perception the perceptions
in the world
i could do with this film and it was
important for me to show that my country
is full of sophistication
and how at that time all the great
thinkers around the world would
come to mexico it just steps out
of the stereotypes that were used
for all latin american uh characters
at the time you know in the end of the
90s because remember i
i was trying to get this done for a very
long time
there's so many things about her like
her courage to be unique
also like not only there was the
situation of mexico
a way to also physically show mexico
which was so beautiful the colors of
mexico the light of mexico
the art of mexico the music of mexico
and um the sophistication and culture
and cultural richness but also
she like i said she had the courage to
be unique and i thought that
that would be inspired inspiring
beyond the latin american community that
her life would be inspiring
for every woman and for every man so
it was not just one more movie that i
wanted like oh it will be my
no for me i really felt like it was my
destiny to make these you know
and and to do it the right way
to do it the right way senor rivera
diego who are you what do you want
i have something important to discuss
with you
i'm working i'll wait
i for real produce this film it's like i
practically did it on my own because i
had no support from miramax
and one of the problems why the many
people that tried to do it before
one of the problems they ran into were
the rights to the paintings
so i befriended a woman dolores almeida
that actually became i learned a lot
from her and she said
you have to woo me i ended up wooing her
for
a couple of years and we became really
good friends and
she said to me you had me a hello i was
always gonna give you this i just wanted
you close to me and i said
you had me at hello too i would have
stayed close to you i had to negotiate
a lot of places that had never allowed
anyone to shoot in there before
i did the cast by myself all the cast in
the united states every single
name that we found that were all friends
um
that did it as a favor except um
no they were all friends they were all
friends some more than others but they
were all friends
they say if a girl asks your opinion and
she's not a complete
fright you'll gush all over her
i need you to tell me one thing honestly
do you actually believe that i should
continue to paint
yes
yes well the truth is that after we
finished it uh in the post-production
i was so emotionally
and physically exhausted from the
journey
that i kind of said i did it and i kind
of stepped out
for for some time but when it when it
was going to come out i had to step in
again because
first of all it was they were going to
put it just on television
and um so we had to converse
convince harvey to put it on the
theaters but he was saying it was not no
good
it was not worth a theater and then
when he tested high he was upset and
finally he
was gonna put it only at the beginning i
think only two
two theaters or only one theater i
convinced him four more
and then little by little it started
adding theaters but the success
was not immediate it was little by
little and it was
very exciting to see how it had legs on
its own it stood up on its own
against the lads and how it still stands
on its own you know after so many years
hitman's wife bodyguard this is a a
sequel to
the first film hitman's bodyguard
somebody was working at the time
in millennium who is a friend
from frida that was working at miramax
from frida
he told me look i have this role
i know you would not normally do it but
i need you to do this for me because
i want this character to be
unforgettable because it's very
important for the film
because it's about her but she's not in
it he knows that
i really like and and actually i'm it's
terrible that i say but i'm actually
really good at creating characters
she used to be irish by the way and so
i had a lot of freedom and then ryan
who's married to a really good friend of
mine said come on let's do this come on
come on you have to do
so they shot it in this part in london
so it was
easy for me because it's where i live
now and it was two days and we had a lot
of fun and patrick the director also was
super cool and they let me create a
character and
god too the movie comes out it's a big
hit and turns out the audience really
loved the characters so for the sequel
patrick came to me and he said
i want to incorporate sonia into
you know the the duo make it a a
three-handed instead of two-handed with
the guys and
so we worked on the character together
she said tell me about sonia and
i just love the character i could talk
about sonia nonstop
and so she's mad
but there is a there's a logic to her
madness
and i understand it really well and i
love
the way she she thinks out of the box
like
what happens in her head is like really
unexpected
but there's a consistency to it and um
it's also a woman dealing with
menopause probably that it's in denial
of it
and so when you have crazy and you add
the hormones then the
result of that equation is sonia kincaid
in this new movie